[Musique]
avant je me posais des tas de questions
du genre Scott tu es un ancien détenu
comment tu as pu devenir un Avenger
c'est délirant
mais où que j'aille j'entends toujours
la même chose
beaucoup de gens ont encore besoin
d'aide alors on a fabriqué cet appareil
[Musique]
c'est comme un satellite pour l'espace
mental mais version quantique attends
j'aimerais comprendre tu es en train
d'envoyer un signal dans la dimension
subatomique
[Musique]
tout de suite
c'est quoi cet endroit
c'est un univers caché à l'intérieur
d'une autre
de quoi tu as peur
je ne vous ai pas tout dit
[Musique]
cette dimension
n'est pas ce que vous croyez
bien
[Musique]
je peux vous aider à rentrer chez vous
et aussi vous faire gagner du temps
mais ce sera au lendemain
alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
Ant-Man